le septième comité d'orientation
stratégique du tourisme s'est tenue au
conseil départemental piloté par le
préfet le président de région et la
présidente du département sous le
secrétariat de liberté cette réunion
porte sur les grands projets
touristiques à venir sur le territoire
c'est l'occasion de partager ses grandes
orientations dans le cadre de nos
compétences respectives
donc c'est un travail partenarial qui
est absolument nécessaire mais on a paru
aujourd'hui d'un certain nombre de
sujets comme les gîtes sur le volcan
matra sur mende écolodge aussi le
sentier du littoral
donc c'est vraiment toute une gamme de
sujets vue et que nous partageons et
nous en partageant les conclusions et ça
facilite l'élaboration et la réalisation
de ses objectifs en 2015 près de quatre
cent vingt-six mille touristes ont
choisi la destination réunion 75% de
cette clientèle est originaire de la
métropole
le cost souhaite donc attirer de
nouveaux marchés émetteurs comme la
chine et l'inde
le développement de cette économie à la
réunion nécessite une progression du
tourisme à l'international ainsi qu'une
augmentation des dépenses liées au
séjour au jour d'aujourd'hui l'économie
touristique c'est 365 millions d'euros
qui sont injectés par les touristes dans
l'économie réunionnaise donc c'est quand
même une puissance économique très
importante qu'il faut développer
aujourd'hui un touriste dépense en
moyenne 75 euros par jour et on aimerait
le faire passer de faire doubler ou
tripler et pour ça il faut lui proposer
différents produits d'autres produits
pour qu'ils dépensent plus sur nos
territoires
à chaque jour qui passe les orientations
de ce septième cost porte sur le
renforcement de la notoriété de lille à
l'étranger ainsi que le développement
d'une offre d'hébergement à forte valeur
ajoutée
les autorités ont également débattu sur
la construction d'un éco gîte aux
volcans de la réalisation d'un éco lodge
au volcan également ainsi que la
réalisation d'un sentier littoral tout
autour de l'île
donc c'est important pour nous de se
dire comment dans les perspectives qui
viennent avec les professionnels du
tourisme
nous construisons des nouveaux produits
en proposant à au tourisme à
l'international des produits de qualité
et j'ai envie de dire un certain type de
tourisme
que ce soit sur la mer sur le tourisme
culinaire le tourisme de randonnée
à nous de rendre attractif notre notre
notre pays en offrant des vrais produits
de qualité